welcome to this video against the
Rainmaker set mr. Nobbs if I keep
screwing this up yet okay I play
something of BTM against one nighter 3b6
that has them it really is better than
it looks I know it looks pretty awkward
but it's not that terrible this is one
of the ideas why does in a slight slight
trouble now here with the center don't
really see how he avoids material losses
now mm-hmm so the question is politics
on my tics and night takes looks very
natural so I'm going to do that echo
that's less aggressive let's arrest him
rope arrest him a little bit so I can i
push even more here and I'll joya age
for looks kind of it isn't ready
make a lot of sense
anyway that's let's have some let's have
some fun iam I go to five maybe Bishop
g5 I have Queen g5 but this is of course
the two elementary tactics into the hope
that you mrs. it still worth mentioning
there should be three looks normal
yeah p should be three I mean I'm not
very well developed so the whole
situation is it's not clear at all
why not just be sure be three years now
some great alternative I came because
queen d 5 there is the bishop move well
I have Quincy form we should be at night
it will check rinse the Queen
he takes looks totally awkward actually
but if Quincy for be three Queenie to
what kind of nonsense is that it's
really really weird and he's got this
chick there okay I'm taking any way I
mean if i go and i'm going back here he
cannot really take that rook but Bishop
e3 is a is a strong I guess here now
yeah because no I cannot play this
mentioned tech tech Queens you fire them
in
that was a really really really stupid
game by black yeah what was basically
losing out of the opening and I want
some screwed-up totally wow I just
played this far to lose if you if you
want to use that phuket oh wow
you can just take take g7 and I really
don't see anything creative but what I
added really didn't see what else to do
he maybe has route 64 at some point well
this is a simple way to do it and not
bad at all just threaten this this check
and that i'm not sure about really so
that's so great hmm ok Queen f7 is
really a maid so I have to do this
Quincy success is something wow wow how
is he like what I don't get it I am what
are you planning here have three or
something and the bishop is hanging now
oh yeah irritated him so much that she
check that he screwed it up check maybe
this one huh
time warning yeah but maybe just this
wait lots not that click if I'm ticking
here and then then just run for it
should work out yep check Queen g5
Kingda seven loop t4 check King c7 and
don't believe it check check
check
check okay white resigns oh that was
super lucky I mean yeah I'm basically
just winning I just have to do something
no I mean have won the Big D for porn ah
now can I was that was to lose and maybe
this is actually ok but I have forwarded
it afterwards what's bad this is a bad
move this is just a bad move something
like that maybe with this option open
the computer gives this which makes
quite a bit of sentence like this and
here my king is quite safe and this is
kind of annoying yeah then the meat made
idea on g2 and this idea yeah that looks
pretty good for black but this is just a
bad idea yeah I should lose somehow I
guess Bishop there wait what's the ng
giving rook to you warned there with the
winning advantage so what he did is just
fine here yeah and rook Tafoya I I
mentioned this move briefly at this
window I didn't really I couldn't
calculate it but that really looked
terribly dangerous
check check and wins the tickets cannot
survive that attack well now eNOS this
also wins Queen g5 is stronger or this
is true thank you check check something
like that yeah my king it's it's a mess
ready hate this losers however before
loses he has to go back to you for me
know okay it's just rotten and here I'm
winning the amazing a very lucky escape
check check check check check check Luke
evade was winning yeah anyway it's
winning in any case oh that was really
close call thanks for watching